so do a little something acoustically I  know foreigner we always think of like  the whole big presentation but do give  us a song now one of the classic songs  we hear all the time here they are  foreigner Mick Jones Kelly Hanson and  Jeff Pilson go ahead thanks man all  right man  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  the mountain  say look non-first Oh Missy  that's what it takes me baby  so how much you mean to me well I guess  it's just the woman in you brings out  the man  [Music]  I can't help myself you all in the world  to me  [Music]  like the first time  marry  feels like the bird  [Music]  spend my time so foolishly  now that I've found you to make this  career and I know it must be the woman  in you brings out the mailing me I'm now  I can't help my face  you  feels like a bird  feels like the very first time  feels like the first time  very  [Applause]  [Music]  very fast  won't you open up the dough won't you  open up it down  [Music]  turn  [Music]  you